si se espera que en contados minutos ya
la cámara de representantes que es de
mayoría demócrata apruebe este paquete
de ayuda económica de 19 millones de
dólares paquete de ayuda económica que
incluye cheques de 1400 dólares a
estadounidenses que ganen menos de 80
mil dólares al año también 300 dólares
semanales a las personas desempleadas y
aquí es precisamente donde los
demócratas quieren avanzar rápidamente
porque estos esta ayuda de desempleados
semanales se acaba en cerca de una
semana así entonces los demócratas
quieren pasar esto cuanto antes una vez
sea firmada entonces sea aprobada en la
cámara de representantes la ley pasará a
oficina del presidente para ser firmada
y los estadounidenses entonces puedan
empezar a recibir lazio contaron que
estaba la herencia aspectos cuáles
serían los retos que tiene este plan de
rescate
claro y lo que muchos congresistas tanto
republicanos como demócratas están
diciendo es que la clave está en la
implementación es decir temen mucho de
que muchas ayudas por ejemplo la ayuda a
la renta la ayuda a los recién nacidos
que se va a firmar también en este
paquete de 1,9 millones de dólares se
demore mucho en llegar y empiecen a
llover las críticas y es que no
solamente es esta el cheque de 1400
dólares que pues se van a recibir los
estadounidenses sino otro tipo de ayudas
también a nivel local y federal y se le
preocupa mucho a varios analistas y acá
en el congreso precisamente eso la
burocracia que demore la ayuda para que
los estadounidenses puedan pues tener
algún tipo de de descanso frente a esta
crisis económica que se vive en este
país